today the college has adopted a new  methodology for the accession  negotiations this is the first element  in a renewal enlargement strategy the  second element then in our discussions  is also going to be about launching the  accession negotiations with North  Macedonia and Albania and the third one  is going to be a major economic  development plan for the entire region  which we hope that the Zagreb summit can  endorse enlargement is a key political  project which is a firm merit-based and  full membership prospect for the entire  region this is a geo geo strategic  investment that we all need to make  [Music]  you  [Music]